And here's a writer I love.
I have actually,
this is a man of war and I borrowed my,
my best friend,
Amy Beach,
was a beautiful a nature writer.
She wrote this line about men of war.
The man of war appears to be one
individual like Leo Tolstoy,
but it's actually many individuals
living together as a colony.
Like Leo Tolstoy said,
tolstoy.
She,
he starts in my head more big wise than
anybody else in the world.
So for years,
tolstoy ended his journal each day with
three letters and they show for the
Russian if I live every month.
He began with the note nearer to death.
So a few weeks ago I actually went to
Russia and I visited a yes,
Naya,
pollyanna.
He stayed outside Moscow and there I
learned that he had failed many things
in life.
He failed assets,
schools as an educator,
he failed at breeding horses.
He failed at farming and of course he
also failed eventual in his religious
endeavor.
Pretty much the only thing he didn't
fail it was to be a writer and asset
babble in the Russian writer.
One of my favorite writers said,
if the world could,
if the world could write by itself,
I would write like tolstoy
and I take that to mean,
you know,
we know there are big ways and small
ways in life.
If you're,
if the world wrote itself like it is
Super Spolan or Porsche,
there'll be all big wise but was tolstoy
there.
The balance of big ways and small lies.
The big wires.
For many,
I'm a psychiatric ward and to sell too
many people outside in the world can be
summarized as such.
Why live?
Why suffer and why suffer on now any one
of us had I answered there and I think
particularly for those who have
experienced mental illness,
there's also another question we cannot
answer.
Why are you you?
And there are many variations of the
questions.
Why are you not happy?
Why can't you stay hopeful?
Why can't you see the bright side of the
world?
Why are you so selfish?
Why can't you just be like everyone
else?
Why can't you be real?
Why can't you be rational?
The big lies a timeless questions any
asking them.
And then not being able to find answers.
One puts oneself in the timeless trap.
Anyone suffering severe depression may
have the experience,
the time coming to stop one day to the
next,
one minute to the next time,
which is the most precious possession we
have becomes the most treacherous thing.
It's time real.
It's time rational.
Is there a way for us to experience time
in the real world and rational manner?
Okay.
Time in the world of physics is probably
one of the most democratic experience.
I would say tom's minute,
as long as my minute a dictator stays.
No one,
not one seconds longer than my day,
but time experienced by each individual
as we all know is so much less
scientific,
so much less reliable
in life.
There are a big license small wise,
easily.
We look around at our lives and come up
with abundance.
Small why's,
why do I agree to eat at this
restaurant?
But now they want to cross the street,
which was what I really wanted to go.
Why do I read the news first thing in
the morning when I know I shouldn't?
Because that makes me burn my children's
toast.
Why do I want to train for a marathon
and here is one of my favorite wise,
not asked by me,
but by an older man.
When he was the one,
he listened to my public radio and he
said,
why did I tell myself this morning?
Now that piece of cake I ate was good
for me.
Okay,
but we don't,
but we don't live to answer all these.
Small wise,
we shouldn't and exhausted,
exhausted parent of small child can
relate to that.
Why do I have to wear shoes?
Why do I have to brush my teeth?
Why can't I sleep in the dog bed?
Where's the puppy?
Yeah,
and then there are the big wise,
the big why's are not always answerable.
In fact,
we may say that they're big lies because
they can be answered.
One of the danger of living is that
inevitably we run into people who think
that why has an answer and they think
man has to answer for them and when we
can provide a satisfactory answer,
they will do that for us often with a
hasty and judge.
A Manto answer.
Big whys are life and death or on a
piece that small wise,
when we can find answers,
well,
one,
we don't even have to find answers,
but just to acknowledge them,
insulate and sustain us.